μέχρι σήμερα συκάποιο κότο που εκτυμό και είμαστε μπαρές γιατί γιακνο που είμαι αλλά είτε
είνι αρχος ένειμε δήμαρχο οτο μέσα σε πρεκλοτυχε να θάσει άτομα που ήταν κοντά στων
αντρεβήνα εί να χάσω έτσι να πληγωθώ να το πω ναι έτυχε ότι έναι περίμενα
ν κάποιες συμπηρηφορές που κάποιο κόσμον οείναμε με εψηφυσια έσ γανα ξεκαθαρίσουν ι διατραγόμε ένα
πολιτικόμ να τομο και ανοίκο σε κόμα να αντρωπή μου να κρίμο κάποιον άλλο πολιτοποιμένον
που ανκιςάλο κόνμοε θα με ψηφύσει έσι για να ξεκαθαρίζω ότι εγώ έθα εβαλονα τον
εψήφηζαν ήταν αν υποψήφιος με άλλον κόμα ενώ ι ανκις άλλον κόμ να του τον
πουλέω λέε ότι ρ άνθρωποι που ετρόαμε επίννα υπήρχε μνα εκτύμηση τις εκλωές άκους κατηγορίες
άκουες κιο γιτες το δεμα μεντος ο άνθωπος που κπ να με ψηφύσει έτσι για
να ξεκαθαρίσωτού το πράμα φίσι για να που πιπουις ναι εμπρόμε να παντιμετωίτε και συνηθήσε
υπάρχου λύσει σε ότι αφορά τις μεταγκινήσεις γιατί και το κυκλοφοριακόστηλλά να καενα πρόβλημα π
αντιμετωποιζει ο κόσμους ιδικά κοντά στις φυνικούδ ις κιτην περ αντιλαβάνεσε ότι στηλλάνε να κάνα
μέχρι πρόσφατα εν είχαμε ταπροβλήμασε αλλές ποίς αλλά πάει να δημουγηθεί να το θέμα να
πωότι έχουμε όλες τις λύσεις να παλέψεμα αντιθέτος έχουν το σβάκτος σχυδιοβί με υτικής κυνοδικας
που δέκα οκτό έκατομυρία ευρώ και να δω καιοι κάποιες λσεις αλλά να όκει κάποιε
λύσεις να κάνει ττις υποδομές για να μπορεις να αλλάξεις κουτούρ ενακιομο να λύσει όπβλη
αλλά τουλάχι των τωρα σ να πο είν πο από δηλαδο κατώ αφέ χει πο
τηλαδότρμο να σε τ πιεής η να πείρνο μ λεφροικαφέρε ι λεωφορείον υπώς εαπανής θέλω
θέλω απ εία ότι τοράιτων να κάνει τις υποδομίες για να σπρώξεις μετά την κουτούρα
να χρισμοπιούνται τον που ναμεπολτε σεαλί των κόσμο ανα αυτο γιτομε στο καρά αλλά εντο
διαστην υπόδομινιονα να πτοπληρώνωσο πδό λαλί να διαχωρίζω τα οργανικά α τα διαχωρίζω επου να
τα παίρνοναι θα τ διαχωρίζωω κια τα παίρνω κι κου παίρνω και τ άλλα ήτα
να κάμονοτο το πράμα άα θέλω από ότι πρώταπρέακάμει την υποδομή